because who came to the set of Game of
Thrones the Queen yes thanks yeah got a
picture over there she is
she looks so unimpressed after they kept
trying to push her to sit down on the
throne and we kept getting told the same
thing which is she's not allowed to sit
on other Thrones fictional or otherwise
[Laughter]
did you talk to her
I did yes yeah and she was delightful
talk about not much she asked me a
question I said yes ma'am and then she
moved on what did she ask you couldn't
beat anything and what do you do on this
production you said yes wonderful and
moved on and seven Thrones she said
looks very uncomfortable well I think
you missed out on the perfect
conversational gambit because no an
ancestor of yours didn't they do
something wonderful for a previous Queen
yes listen this is good leader gentleman
Queen Elizabeth the first it was Sir
John Harington and the embedded the
flushing toilet no because you were
saying or it was the other guy and it
wasn't it John crapper and then the the
word crapper comes from Thomas Crapper
Thomas Crapper Thomas Crapper
he ever the word John the John comes
from John Hanson
so it wasn't crap a crapper just came in
France much enjoyed whatever he made it
into mass production
well you would know better than me he
related to the guy yeah
so let's follow the John because of him
yeah yeah Wow that's much more polite
than crapper was it your why is it more
polite that's the thing Jonah now become
more of a polite term for it the John or
like crap really poorly researched who
do you think you are ever maybe I don't
know yeah
any which way and who
[Music]
you